what we're going to do is going to raise
your hands both of them really high into
the air also a very good stretch early
in the morning when it's not am which I
know many of you probably don't get up
that early on Saturdays so keep your
hands raised so you're gonna you're
gonna is that the highest you can raise
your hands yeah ah so keep raising them
so collectively we're all gonna just
just go what like just a little bit more
just like a few inches more and so the
point of this is that we can all reach a
little bit higher okay alright so now
that we started that on a good note and
technology is sorted out I tweeted this
there's gonna be a fun talk I tweeted
this because I was so excited and then
my team actually called me out and they
said well you actually have to tell a
joke then so here it here comes okay
that's it alright so my name is my name
is Kelly gin and I'm super pumped to be
here to talk to you guys this morning I
think what has been really interesting
my current position is that I turn into
a butterfly come january twentieth so
you're if you were going to ask that
question I turn into a butterfly come
january twentieth 2017 there are we are
still running very very fast so the
president just did his South paisano
South by South Lawn event last week
there's going to be the frontiers
conference next Thursday this Thursday
actually in Pittsburgh so the president
is still pushing on a lot of Science and
Technology events and I myself I work
with in the office of the chief
technology officer Megan Smith for those
of you who have heard her speaking for
and I also work very closely with DJ
Patil the very first used us chief data
scientist so
we're going to start off today by
telling a story and all good stories
start in Boston which is where I'm from
so I actually spent the last two years
Boston's not only my hometown but
actually spent the past two years in
Boston building up the data team there
so the new mayor came in mayor Walsh in
2014 and he was really thinking about
how can we make better data driven
decisions throughout local government in
Boston and for those of you who've heard
there are a lot of really cool things
that haven't happened over the past two
years I also started when we had the
worst winter ever so I literally started
January Monday January 26 and then for
the next month and a half I had many
days off from work so this is a photo I
believe of Newbury Street but things
were shut down so it was a great welcome
when I went back to Boston to start work
there when I arrived there was actually
a news article that was talking about
this project called snow stats so I
believe the link is snow stats Boston
gov you can't actually access it right
now because thankfully there's no snow
on the ground there but it actually
showed you so you think about all of the
citizens who are stuck at home wondering
what are the plows going to come you
were actually able to log into a website
and see how much snow had been cleared
in your local area depending on the
street and just gave citizens a better
sense of you had all of these public
works guys out there digging out but
oftentimes there was a huge disconnect
between what you kind of like peeked
outside and looked through the window
and what was actually going on so this
was my premise for joining the city of
Boston and City Hall I was like wow
they're so advanced and they're doing so
many cool things and everything must be
really really great and it was to a
certain extent I think for those of you
who've worked in government or even an
industry I'm sure is a good split here
you are faced with a lot of challenges
so I'm going to talk about today is now
not only filling potholes like the title
says but also then how do we move past
those challenges and how do we start
thinking about things at a very very
high level at a federal and national
level to connect a lot of these
different cities so oftentimes when I
speak to audiences I always say I asked
this question like what are we actually
doing right as government employees as
public servants what are we actually
doing at the end of the day and so this
marker of improved quality of life i
think this thread carries itself whether
you're in local government for those of
you who enjoy watching parks or
recreation the TV show it is very
similar to that and then for those of
you who watch some other political TV
shows federal government is not quite
that interesting at all but we are all
trying to improve quality of life i will
say that is the the common thread of the
work that we're doing this is just a
photo from one of the community centers
in boston i think one thing that is
really important for all of you as you
go out and you work looking at massive
amounts of data is that oftentimes that
comes back to one individual right you
are looking at one record of an
individual's interaction with government
right if you go on to day to gov you can
see a lot of those very public data sets
a lot of cities are also releasing their
data through open data portals and so
for me I'm constantly thinking of well
that was an interaction in Boston we
have still population is about 650,000
there are about 17,000 employees of the
city and so I was constantly thinking of
my mind how many of those interactions
between employees and with citizens or
people visiting the city we're happening
each day and how much information did we
actually have to track and and look at
that quality of of data a lot of the
work that we're doing is helping
government really ask and answer better
questions I look at into this audience
and I think that oftentimes and I myself
have struggled with this
you go to an executive or you go to a
manager you're go to a leader and
they're just pummeling you with
questions right well like what about
this well you looked at the data and now
I have like a thousand more questions
and to me that is a marker of success if
you are actually able to go out do
analysis and have an executive who is
constantly bubbling you with more
questions in the case of DJ that is the
president of the United States is
constantly asking him more questions in
the case of working in local government
that is the case of the mayor asking you
more questions about what's going on in
the case of industry you I'm sure you're
getting asked questions by your CIO and
your CFO of not only okay you've looked
at the data and you're able to say these
are some of my conclusions but at a
higher level will then one right what
are we then able to derive from your
initial conclusions so remember that
really cool slide that I showed you that
was the dashboard of the snow stats so I
got to Boston and that was not reality
so this was more reality of what things
were like on the ground which is the
mayor had gone to New York City and
spoken to Bloomberg and for those of you
who know anything about Bloomberg a very
very fancy charts about how the stock
market is moving in any given
millisecond right things are not the
same at the local government level so
this is one of the first versions of the
mayor's dashboard of the things learned
here is number one never put a blank
screen and a politician together in the
same photo because I will not show you
any of the other images but people
Photoshop some other things that the
Mayor was looking at
so that's lesson number one but less
number two more importantly even though
this is just a black screen with some
grass on it was really just built in and
Google Docs is that we actually weren't
able to get all this data right so the
mayor actually cared about a lot of
these things you can't quite read it in
the back but it says potholes filled
graffiti removed code violations issued
etc these are things that executives and
in turn six care about right because
we're paying our our hard-earned dollars
into into taxes and what are we actually
getting as a result of that and so this
is one of my first lessons of okay the
mayor has all these questions we have a
lot of questions but what can we get up
and running as soon as possible so a lot
of the work that I am constantly
thinking through is that sometimes it
just needs to be good enough and let's
get it out the door let's ship it let's
show it to the mayor and get his
feedback right let's not wait six months
let's not wait a year to actually
deliver out a product in terms of how
are we actually doing as a city and so
this is a very very good example of some
of building something very very small
that that gets a lot of interest from
both the mayor and the public this is
one of my favorite comics I don't I
don't even know why I stuck it in here
but I really like it and it's on the
board at work I feel like to me um I
don't maybe some of you are also this
like little like the larger marshmallowy
data guy but oftentimes right in
different organizations you are
constantly saying well okay you have a
hunch can we look at the data and can we
validate that hunch or maybe you have a
hunch we're actually not collecting that
data right now and so a lot of times
this kind of interaction perhaps not
this adorable but oftentimes this kind
of interaction is happening within
organizations and so I just want to take
a brief pause in and show that starting
the dialogue so I think in my very very
long title somewhere in there it's a
data-driven dialogue and and I say
dialogue because it is often a
back-and-forth right so I in my career
always been at this intersection
of business technology and data and
sometimes it requires a fair bit of
translating between the different
parties involved it all has to start
with actually having a conversation I'm
going to talk I promise I will switch to
stop talking about boss on a certain
point but this is a screenshot of the
311 application so for those of you who
at least live in DC i'm not aware of the
app being used in Virginia but 311 is
basically the number that you call
that's not 911 so if you have an actual
service request that you know have you
have a question about the city let's say
you're in Washington DC or in this
scenario you need a pothole filled you
can actually call a number and most
cities across the u.s. have started to
adopt this so in Boston you're actually
able to take a photo of that pothole and
then what happens is the city worker who
fills that pothole actually takes a
photo when they're done and they send it
back to you so you actually know hey
somebody listen to me in government
right oftentimes it's a black box
somebody actually listen to me and
somebody actually filled filled it and
we have photo evidence hopefully that it
was filled the first time I saw this I
was like wait a minute the lines don't
quite mad shop and it took me a while to
wrap my mind around that but my point
here is that this is a great example of
dialogue it is so simply done right
let's take a photo let's end it between
individuals or able to show
accountability and so for me on the back
end right this is then a ton of data
that were then able to access so the
mayor actually version like 10 of the
mayor's dashboard is now able to look at
a ton of different metrics all
throughout the city of things that he
cares about that is Chiefs care about
you're talking about city services
education Public Safety what are people
actually doing day to day
and this is something that he pushed
very very very strongly in the upper
right hand corner you can kind of make
out it says Boston 3 11 so that
application that you just saw as well as
people calling in that was being updated
every 10 seconds so the mayor was able
to see pretty much real time what are
people calling it about what are some of
those major thing is happening
throughout the city and then of course
if something major is happening years
it's like and I've waited out there any
of those emergency alerts happening as
well picture yourself as like the mayor
or the head of any organization right
it's really really hard for those of you
who've managed like teams of 10 or 20
it's also really hard what are people
doing right how can I be helpful to
those individuals just getting a finger
on the pulse of what's going on is
something that people in government
struggle with all the time and so a lot
of that has to do with how can you
surface that information in a way that
they're able to actually digest and it
was something that I have constantly
been obsessing about is that the ability
to tell your story is the ability to get
action done right to get somebody to
actually take action and move forward on
something I have violated all rules of a
number of words on a slide here but my
point actually here is that there are a
ton of issues you guys can read some of
this very easily there are a lot of
things that we face and if you think
about any of these lines here they not
only translate at the local level they
also rise up to the federal level right
you have a federal agency for public
health health and human services NIH
homelessness HUD right Education
Department of Education so all of these
issues what's been incredibly
fascinating to me is seeing them at the
local level and then three months ago
coming back to DC and say holy cow all
these federal agencies are also running
out these issues right and how can they
be effective
they don't have data if they don't have
that much information and so a lot of a
work that DJ and the team have been
doing is really on unlocking a lot of
information whether that is giving that
to you as people here to students to
actually do analysis on a lot of that
has to do with how can we get the data
into the hands of people who can do
something about it I highlighted the
very last thing because when I came back
to DC I actually didn't know what I was
going to be working on there's a
thousand different projects and for
those of you who've worked in government
or worked in DC oftentimes what is
incredibly important on the national
stage ends up something that you're
working on day to day and so last night
as I was pulling these slides and
finalizing them i said i'm going to talk
about this very last piece because
that's what i'm doing and actually i'll
talk a little bit about my trip to los
angeles as well this past week i I think
I've like this weird jetlag thing where
I've just completely dissociated from
the 24-hour cycle so you guys are kind
of dealing with the results of that on
on Saturday morning all right so I'm
read this law enforcement how do we
divert individuals with mental illness
away from our jails to the services that
they actually need it's a tough problem
I'm from Boston so it's also a wicked
problem and what I mean by wicked
problem for those of you who have never
heard of the phrase before is that it is
a problem that think about any of these
major problems that public policy school
kids or political people scratch their
heads every single day they're like well
yeah that's a really really hard problem
right and so I think of these as wicked
problems where oftentimes they're not
defined oftentimes they are very much
connected to other problems right if we
go back you can think of individuals who
go through our education systems that
might then end up in our
public touching our public health and
agencies might end up then interacting
with law enforcement right all of these
pieces are interconnected and so it's
not a straightforward problem we have to
be creative about the ways that we
actually approached them all right I'm
going to finally talk about what I
actually doing in DC so of course I
didn't have enough in Boston I was like
everything is so easy at the local level
which is not true at all but I had an
interesting conversation with DJ and DJ
being DJ is a very convincing individual
and so somehow i ended up three months
ago at the end of june coming back to DC
and really thinking about what can we
move the needle on at a national level
fully understanding that there at the
time was about six months left in this
administration right so what can we
actually do it's kind of a question to
be posed then I saw this stat my first
week as i was reading through materials
so 11.7 million americans in 30 100
local jails cost us over 20 billion
dollars per year it doesn't say per year
but it's actually per year and so it's a
huge problem huge literally this is a
photo of Cook County Jail Chicago is
located within Cook County Jail it is 96
acres the glitter Lee we drove on to the
jail and then on our way out we got
stuck in traffic and I was like are we
are we back in Chicago and they're like
no we're still on the jail complex we're
just stuck in traffic because there's so
many people who work there and so we
were stuck in traffic for like an hour
in this 96 acre complex try to get back
into downtown Chicago and this is not
unusual so to me this is one of those
moments where you kind of say holy cow
right I feel like there's oftentimes we
look at an
this happened in Boston as well you're
looking at a data set and someone tells
you just a few numbers and you're like
that cannot be right and then someone
then get hands you more data and you're
like that is right but I can't believe
it is right right so I think a lot of
the initiatives that we're working on is
in the scenario like this right how many
people find themselves driving into a
jail and then doing a visit not many
right but I think the work that we've
been doing is going out into the field
and helping to better connect these
local level local level problems with
both federal agencies as well as I spend
some of my weekends talking to awesome
folks like you so that you understand
that these are some of the major issues
that were running through as the country
if I were to ask you what the three
largest providers of mental health
services are most people raise their
hand and be like oh they're like
hospitals and you know someplace or like
whatever actually our country's three
largest jails so that's la cook county
which I just talked about and Rikers New
York City those are the population
average populations of the jails in any
given moment so you have 19,000 people
in LA County Jail and there's multiple
locations of it for those of you who are
interested in watching a bit more about
it CNN's Lisa Ling did a segment about
two weekends ago she spent 10 days going
and visiting the jails and interviewing
the deputies and the sheriff's there and
it was insane absolutely insane like
it's one of those moments where you're
like I would never think I would go to
jail and then you're in jail and you're
like holy cow like this is something
that unless you've gone through this or
you work here you have absolutely no
understanding of the issues at hand so
back to my original question and my
answer which is that these are the three
largest providers of mental health
services in LA alone 4,500 people of
those on average 19,000 have been
diagnosed with a mental health issue and
so right now in our country at any given
moment we have all of these individuals
who are sitting in jail instead of
getting the services that they need let
that sink in on a Saturday morning for
you guys I will compound that with
saying that across my earlier slide with
the large numbers of all of the
individuals in our local jails
sixty-four percent of them have some
sort of mental illness sixty-eight
percent of them have some sort of
substance abuse disorder forty-four
percent of them have chronic health
problems it is crazy and so I promise
this will all make sense at a certain
point uh but there are things being done
at the local jurisdiction level so one
of the reasons why i thought this
problem was so interesting it was
because coming from City Hall I
understood that local jurisdictions are
running at these all by themselves right
they have limited resources everybody's
totally taxed they have to figure out
what can they do and so we were chatting
with one individual in Chicago and she's
working on a thousand different
initiatives these are all incredible
public servants like she might have been
Leslie Knope in parks and recreation and
I said where do you go where do you know
you have all these issues and you're
trying to like unlock the data from your
systems you're trying to connect to
people across the country you're trying
to find solutions where do you go and
she says I don't know I just kind of
like Google and see if i can find
solutions of like other jurisdictions
who have the same issues and if you go
back to that slide that i just talked
about when you know that every single
jurisdiction across the country is
running at these issues it shouldn't
have to be that way right we should do a
better job about connecting people so i
will talk about miami-dade florida when
they actually looked at their number
they found that 97 people accounted for
13.7 million dollars in services over
four years spending over 39,000 days in
different facilities but of course for
those of you who work at any
organization you know that different
departments like never talk to one
another right so think about this right
different counties an individual might
cycle through their jail and then end up
in a hospital ER and then end up in a
homeless shelter and then end up getting
other public health services but none of
those actually talk to one another so
you fall you fall through the gaps right
and when Miami was actually able to look
at the data they were able to actually
identify those 97 people so they did
what arguably is a pretty that's not
arguably it is a pretty simple data task
right you pull your people you pull your
people let's sit at a table and actually
compare all of these individuals and
figure out who is taking up the majority
of our days our beds as well so what
Miami was able to do is by having those
conversations and saying we're actually
going to do something about it police
have now responded this is as of last
year police have now responded to nearly
50,000 calls but I've made only 109
arrests and so the real point of this is
that instead of jail instead of
emergency rooms you should be getting
the services that you actually need
right and the jail population fell
there's a lot of these individuals these
are all low-level offenses misdemeanors
but they've been thrown in jail for that
and so they were able to save 12 million
dollars a year it's interesting to me
because people who work in the criminal
justice system lawyers right public
defenders sheriff's they all get this
police departments they all get this
because there they have to deal with
this on a frontline basis every single
day
but the rest of us don't like I have had
many many conversations where i've spent
about five minutes explaining this and
everyone goes that is that can't be
right like why are we doing this right
and so part of this is how do we tell
this story and what do we actually do
about it so we did do something about it
my colleague Lynn Overman who is a
former public defender actually from
Miami built an initiative around it is
called data-driven justice you can
actually look this up there's a website
is live as of end of June they launched
with 67 jurisdictions we now have over a
hundred as of last night 119 and the
population is 91 million jurisdictions
so we've been able to convince 119
jurisdictions no convincing needed they
all raised their hands and said this is
a huge problem please help us and please
help connect the dots as well and so I
am talking to an audience of data
scientists so what we've actually been
able to do about this is to help better
connect resources so this is a photo I
went to the University of Chicago's data
science for social good program that is
run by Reggie Ghani has anybody in this
audience gone through that program nope
so you should apply it's an awesome
summer program it's 14 weeks it's
sponsored by the i believe the erika and
wendy schmidt foundation in university
of chicago and in 14 weeks they worked
with Johnson County Kansas and were able
to identify 200 individuals this slide
says 104 they were actually able to
identify 200 individuals who had been
cycling through all of these systems and
at an absolute minimum cost costing a
quarter of a million dollars because
they were cycling through all of these
systems but no one had actually talked
to one another so they were able to pull
law enforcement data
right in 14 weeks they were able to pull
law enforcement data they were able to
pull EMS data they were able to then
compare that to mental health services
data again you guys in the audience
you're all i know that's super easy no
one had been doing this right no one had
been doing this and so it's been an
incredible experience getting these
fellows to connect to these data sources
and start thinking okay what are the
ways that we can actually what are the
ways that we could actually use our
talent right collectively use our talent
I believe I am I will hurry up a little
bit but I think I'm definitely running
over time use your talent to
operationalize solutions so I am very
passionate about this because if we do
our work right things should change you
should never be building a product you
should never be doing any analysis if
you have not had that initial scoping
conversation to say what are you going
to do about it my results would you how
are you going to implement my
recommendations what budget do you
actually have for that right so a lot of
the work that we're doing at the federal
level is helping a lot of these local
jurisdictions and a lot of those local
jurisdictions are starting to pick that
up as well so that last slide that you
saw Johnson County said we can only
intervene with 200 individuals give us a
list of 200 individuals and we will
intervene and so that is a lot of what
I'm obsessing about is how can we
actually operationalize this work and
there's some challenges there's a lot of
challenges more than this I think the
opportunity is too great I think Megan
Smith our CTO often times says let's do
tours of duty right come into government
then go back out into industry learn
things from from both sides and lastly I
think lastly talk to people so this is a
photo in Boston we have this kind of
funny a funny thing that happens that
when you say we're gonna have a really
small meeting with like five people we
ran out of so you can't quite see but
like on unlike
this imagine like this side of the photo
is all standing room so we wanted to
convene a conversation in Boston about
this very issue and we invited five
people who then invited five other
people and then we had about 40 ish
people crammed into a small conference
room friday at five-thirty p.m. we got
started everyone came everyone stayed we
now have 15 plus jurisdictions that I've
joined because they all think that this
is this is an issue that we need to be
all working on collectively together
talk to people so they told me I
couldn't actually take photos of my
right along so these are photos like
before the ride alongs the I went out to
LA we were actually able to see how
jurisdictions are doing a good job
around these issues a lot of that has to
do with co responder models so how do we
take people who understand how to deal
with individuals with mental health
crisis and couple them with law
enforcement so I see a few kind of last
these are things that I just like could
not believe so there's there's a gang
conference room and on this side um our
team is little shameless so we asked for
a challenge coin that is not my
collection I only have four challenge
coins currently but these are some of
the places that had gone to LA to get
training from those police officers
because they are really thinking about
mental health and how can we do a better
job of responding to those individuals
so I know I turn into a butterfly come
january twentieth i will not be flying
away on a helicopter which is pretty
cool but you should still come join so
the federal government beyond this
administration beyond all of the great
work that i believe the president has
done has institutionalized a lot of this
work so you have 18 f it son of the
General Services Administration you have
the presidential innovation fellows
which got formalized and then you have a
ton of federal agencies as well I know
some folks
commerce are speaking later today or
tomorrow and they are definitely hiring
in the next year I've chatted with some
of the folks there so USA Jobs gov is a
great resource to peruse through there's
a whole other question as i know i am on
record there's a whole other question of
how can the federal government do a
better job of hiring individuals with
all of your skill sets but i think that
is something that is exciting right how
can we collectively start to define what
the role of data science data scientist
in federal government is and what are
the kinds of issues and problems that we
should be running after thank you that's
it